quand on est une vraie star super prof
nous les seniors aja 1 entreprises se
préparent comme une séquence de film
qu'on avoue sécuriser le perfectionnisme
pour ma vie j'avais
femmes violées torturées parier
après vous avoir posé toutes ses ennuis
encore merci et au revoir
ces types c'était qui c'est lui qui m'a
dépanné poulina et un autre avait son
tortionnaire
je sais pas plus
des fils de quelqu'un qui ne sera pas
puni pour reconnaître je les fais le
même je m'en souviendrai de crise et de
répit c'est vous que cette thérapie en
huit lots implacable rigoureusement mise
en scène par roman polanski les
situations de ces trois personnages sauf
il a été celui qui sous celui qui a été
accusé et il a aussi le mari
ce qui est extraordinaire ont détaché
par rapport à tout ça une erreur on n'a
jamais évoqué jamais et chacun de nous
se sent profondément concerné par cette
relation ambiguë bourreau victime
un affrontement qui met en valeur des
pulsions sexuelles et meurtrière à
l'aube de ce procès impitoyable pierre
de châtiment n'écoute pas de continuer à
vivre avec l'horreur